Hello, I'm Dr. Brooke
Schaud-Laurent.
I'm an osteopathic family
medicine physician.
I'm an associate
professor
and chair for
the Department
of Clinical Medicine
at NYIT College
of Osteopathic
Medicine at Arkansas
State University.
I also serve as
the executive
director for the
Delta Population
Health Institute
at NYIT-COM,
the community engagement
arm for the
medical school.
Today, my presentation
will be on health
disparities, Closing
the Gap Through Cultural
Competencies. This is
one of two parts. In
the first part of this
presentation, we'll
be defining what are
health disparities,
explain the contributing
factors of health
disparities,
explain how social
determinants of
health affect
health outcomes, and
explain how
practices in health
care contribute to
health outcomes.
There are many
expectations that will be
expected of you as
rising osteopathic
physicians, and this is
one of them, that you
will have a lifelong
commitment to grow
in the discipline of
cultural competency,
to provide quality
health care to
all persons, and
to lead communities
holistically
and with equity.
this is our definition
of health disparities
it's it's the difference
in the incidence
prevalence mortality
and burden of disease
as well as other adverse
health conditions
or outcomes that
exist among specific
populations well documented
in subpopulations
based on socioeconomic
status, education,
age, race,
ethnicity, geography,
disability, gender, and
or ****** orientation.
Because of the limitation
of time, we won't
be able to get into
the disparities of all
the populations and
demographics. We will
however touch on the
most prevalent ones and
provide references at
the end of this lecture
to learn more about
how other populations
are experiencing health
in the United States.
One of the disparities
that have been
well documented is
life expectancy.
This graph is from
the county health
rankings and shows
health disparities
specifically in life
expectancy among
race and ethnic
groups. The population
with the highest
life expectancy
between 2010 and
2020 is in the Asian
Pacific Islander
population, followed by
the Hispanic
population, then white.
American Indian
and Alaskan Native
follows and then the
Black population.
Please note, excuse
me, that this does not
take into account the
change in life expectancies
after the pandemic.
There are recent
studies that have shown
that the gaps have
widened for minority
populations. You can see
here that the differences
of life expectancy
ranges between 10 to
20 years, depending on
which people group an
individual is part of.
Another disparity
is unfortunately
found in maternal
and child health.
In this diagram in
the upper left side,
it notes that of all
the preterm births
in 2020, 14.4% were in
the Black population
followed by native
hawaiian pacific
islanders american indian
and alaskan natives
where you have preterm
births children
that were born in
preterm have significant
chronic illnesses
as a sequelae
of preterm birth
a higher risk
of having
chronic illnesses
as a sequelae for
preterm births in the
upper right corner
we're looking at
babies born of low
birth rate in 2020.
And in this period,
it was captured that
14.2% of babies
born of low birth
rate were of the black
population followed
by native American
Pacific Islanders
and then American
Indian Alaskan Natives.
For pregnancy
related mortality in
the lower left corner
per 100 births,
40.8 deaths
per 100 births
occurred in the
black population.
The next highly
affected group was the
American Indian, native
Alaskan group by 29
.7 per 100 births.
Then followed by the
Asian population, 12
.7 per 100,000 births.
When you move over to
the right lower corner,
where there's a
measurement of infant
mortality per 1,000
live births in 2018,
again, we see that within
the black population
there's a higher rate
10.8 per 1000 live
births followed by 9
.4 per 1000 births uh
in the native hawaiian
specific pacific
islander group and
then followed by 8.2 in
american indian alaskan
natives so again these
are these graphs
show some staggering
disparities um among
different ethnic and racial
groups and it's important
to note not only
that they are there
but as osteopathic
physicians to understand
why these disparities
exist and we'll be
getting into that a little
bit later on another
intersection not only
lies within race and
ethnicity but also
where you live contributes
significantly to
your health outcomes
this was an article in
rural counties with
majority in health affairs
excuse me that had an
article that showed
rural counties with
majority black or
indigenous populations
suffer the highest rates
of ********* death.
There's a CDC study
done in 2017 that noted
the same. It's important
to note that when
we're looking at these
different populations,
when you have these
different demographics
and they're compounded,
it puts populations
at significant risk
for health outcomes
that are deadly. This
is a map from county
health rankings that
breaks down the geography
of counties across
the United States.
The areas here that
in purple are shown
and have demonstrated
to be the least
healthiest counties. The
area that you see
highlighted here is in
the Mississippi Delta.
This is the region
where the Arkansas
campus is based. And as
you can see, along
with areas in Alaska,
rural areas here
in the southwest,
areas of Appalachia
here and here, Um,
but there are
these significant
disparities and, uh,
these counties are
encountering
significant challenges.
And this map
again shows that
where you live
does matter.
There have been many
studies to show,
um, along a Metro
line, for example, um,
this This is a map
of New York City
that shows the
Metro lines 456 and
line NQR, and
depending what stop
you get off of,
it actually does
determine what your
life expectancy is.
It could be a difference
of close to 10 years.
Here around Lincoln
Center, it's
around 84 years.
If you go to where
the Apollo Theater
is, it's 76.
If you look at
Queens and Astoria,
82 years.
So there are a lot
of studies that
are looking at what
are the environmental
factors that are
causing these
discrepancies and
disparities for
life expectancies
in the same state.
the map that you see
on the right here shows
a similar example
this is a highway in
california where depending
what exit that you
get off of your life
expectancy could be 81
and going further up
north near fresno we
could be 75 so as we're
looking at these studies
we should be looking
and asking what is
going on in these
areas that we have such
significant disparities
in life expectancies.
What I'm making reference
to here in terms
of environmental
factors are what is
known as the social
determinants of health.
The social determinants
of health are
defined are the conditions
in the environments
where people are
born, where they live,
learn, work, play,
worship, and age that
affect a wide range
of health functioning
and quality of life
outcomes and risks.
The six broad
categories or buckets of
social determinants of
health are as follows,
And you'll see some
variation of these
in different
organizations, but they
pretty much fall in
these broad categories.
One is economic
stability, and that is
defined by employment,
income, expenses,
debt, medical bills,
and the support
that they have.
The next category
is neighborhood
and physical
environment, housing,
transportation,
safety,
parks, playgrounds,
walkability, your zip
code. All these things
contribute to the
health outcomes of an
individual or family.
Next is education,
your literacy level,
language, early
childhood education,
vocational training,
the ability to obtain
higher education is
one determinant of
health. And the next
one is food security,
hunger, access to
healthy options.
The next category is
community and social
context, such as
social integration,
a unit in a family
or communities
that have strong
support systems,
a community that
where there's true,
thoughtful community
engagement.
areas where there are
discrimination and
stress can act and
be a significant
determinant of health
and the sixth bucket is
health care system
health care coverage
provide availability
provider linguistic
and cultural competency
and quality of
care for the most
part you as a rising
osteopathic physician
will have the most
authority and influence
in this last column.
And for the most
part, for the rest of
your education, it will
be focusing on your
competencies as a
healthcare professional
in providing care
that is culturally
appropriate and providing
quality of care.
But it's important
to be aware that
these other
columns here are
significant drivers
in health outcomes,
more so than health
care systems.
Health outcomes
are defined as
mortality, morbidity,
life expectancy,
health care expenditures,
health status, and
functional limitations.
So the county health
rankings shows and
provides a diagram
that is very helpful
to see, well, how
much does clinical
care contribute to
health outcomes? So in
this diagram, health
outcome is defined
by length of life
and quality of life.
The areas here are
the health factors
such as health
behaviors, clinical care,
social economic factors,
physical environment.
And it looks like if
you want to have the
greatest and the best
movement of improvement
for health outcomes,
the areas that you
have to affect are
health behaviors, social
economic factors, and
physical environment.
Clinical care is just
20%. It is significant.
There are significant
issues that happen
in a clinical setting
that you will learn
how to avoid and
advocate for patients'
health through these
presentations and the
rest of your education.
But it's also important
to know as an
osteopathic physician,
because we know that if
you approach something,
understanding that
you have to look at
the systems also outside
the human body, where
they live, learn,
work, play, and pray.
If you're aware of those
things, you will be
a better osteopathic
physician, because as
you're taking those
things into consideration,
you'll be able to
customize the appropriate
care for the patient
that is before you.
one of the greatest
misconception in
uh disparities
when they're being
observed is that race
is a biological factor
and nothing can be
further than the truth
it is actually the
act of discrimination
because of race or
any other and a
reason against people
that's a significant
driver of health
disparities and a clear
example of this is in
the practice and
the legalization of
redlining redlining was
a federally supported
discriminate
discriminatory law that
prohibited the granting
of loans to black
individuals and families
which kept black
people and families
from owning properties
forcing them to live
in designated areas.
These areas have
generationally have
been disinvested so
that economic mobility
and stability is
almost non-existent.
Education, options
for healthy foods,
healthy spaces are not
equitable in areas that
were invested where
people could get
loans and buy property.
And these were and
are the major drivers
of health outcomes.
The maps that
you see before
you are maps
of Minneapolis.
The one on the
left are the areas
that have been
redlined. They have the
highest concentration
of people of
color between 1930s
and 1970 by way
of discriminatory
law and practices.
The map on your
right shows the areas
of high infant
mortality in the same
Minneapolis area
between 2001 and 2010.
these areas are the
same areas that were
redlined the areas that
were redlined are the
areas where you have the
highest concentration
of infant mortality
this is an example
of structural racism
while there aren't any
anti-discrimination
laws or or or blatant
discrimination laws to
date The vestiges of
legalized discrimination
are lived experiences
for people today
because of these laws.
The environmental
factors and determinants
of health caused
by redlining are
causing high rate
of infant mortality.
So it's important to
note that you have
to look at the history
of the conditions
of where people
live. That affects
the options and
opportunities of health
that are driving
the health outcomes.
Dr. Williams
published an article
on racism and
health in the Annual
Review of Public
Health in 2019.
It is a significant
publication that I
encourage you to review
to better understand
how the patterns of
racial, ethnic inequities
in health exist,
and we also need to
learn more about it
because we see that
there are rates of
disease and death that
are elevated for
historically marginalized
racial groups such as
black native americans
native hawaiians and
pacific islanders
and if you were
to adjust for
socioeconomic
status which
means if you were
to look at the
people groups who
have the same salary
or socioeconomic status
you still will see
a disparity amongst
ethnic and racial
groups which shows
that it's more than
the amount of money
one may have in their
bank account or their
financial assets.
Research indicates
that across virtually
every type of
diagnostic and treatment
intervention,
****** and other
minorities receive fewer
procedures and poor
quality medical
care than ****** do.
So there is a
significant issue that is
going on in a
healthcare system that
is really important
for you as a rising
osteopathic physician
to be aware of.
another population is
the lgbtq population
um significant
groups uh significant
groups are um within
the lgbt groups
are delaying health
care because of concern
and fear of
discrimination um over
50 percent of lgbtq
plus people report
some form of health
care discrimination
18 percent of lgbt youth
report experiencing
dating violence one out
of five of transgender
people are refused
health care services
there's also financial
health disparities
in providing getting
health health care
services that is much
higher within lgbtq lgbtq
plus groups So it's
important to be aware,
again, of the lack of
access that is causing
health disparities,
but also discriminatory
practices that are
being experienced by
different demographics
within the health care
system that's affecting
health outcomes.
why we might see these
health disparities
specifically in lgbt
groups is that um there's
additional stress
for marginalized
persons who experience
discrimination or stigma
there's lack of access
to adequate health
care services due to
bias or discrimination
in the system policy
or provider level.
Inadequate
public knowledge,
attitudes, and systems.
And health promotion
messages tailored
to LGBT communities
fail to realize
that ****** orientation
identification
is not the same as
****** behavior. And
so there's a lot of
education that needs
to be done in this
area to make sure
people have the
care that they need.
Unequal Treatment,
Confronting
Racial and Ethnic
Disparities
in Health Care
was a landmark
publication by
the Institute
of Medicine,
now known as the
National Institute
of Medicine,
excuse me, the
National Academies of
Sciences. This
landmark study called
Unequal Treatment
really showed through
a panel of experts
who documented
evidence and explored
how persons of color
experience healthcare
environment.
This book examines
how disparities in
treatments may arise in
healthcare systems and
looks at aspects of
the clinical encounter
that may contribute to
such disparities. um
patients and providers
attitudes expectations
and behaviors were
analyzed the um document
also talked about
ways we could improve
um these uh disparities
that individuals
were experiencing
there would be
improvements needed in
medical care financing
allocation of care
availability of
language translation
for those who do
not have English as
a primary language,
community-based care,
and other arenas.
The committee highlights
the potential of
cross-cultural
education to improve
provider-patient
communication and offers
detailed look of how
to integrate cross
-cultural learning within
health professions.
But what has happened
since this
landmark report?
Well, there was a
presentation done
by, presented by
Dr. Brian Smeadley
from the Urban
Institute. He gave a
presentation at the
National Academies
of Science in
February of 2023.
and essentially
provided a perspective
that needed to be
noted, which was, well,
the disparities have
not been narrowed from
the difference of the
year 2000 to 2021.
The Agency for Healthcare
Research Quality
published a report
and saw that for
African, for American
Indian, Alaska Native
populations, the
disparity was reduced only
by 8%. For Asian
populations, 2%. Black
populations, 3%.
Hispanic populations,
4%. Native Hawaiian
Pacific Islanders, 10%.
So we still are seeing
these disparities.
And again, please
keep in mind that we
are still learning
about how the pandemic
it has affected
these health
disparities and
outcomes as well.
Dr. Smedley goes on
to point out, well,
what are the factors
that are associated
with healthcare
inequity? And one thing
that was noted is that
there are separate
and inequitable
healthcare systems due
to residential
segregation, like we talked
about before we saw
in redlining. You
have disinvested
communities where hospitals,
communities aren't
investing, having
good hospitals in
their area. There's a
maldistribution of
healthcare resources,
health systems, limited
provider networks.
There's also a tiered
health insurance
and differences in
provider reimbursement.
And this really does
drive the type of
care that individuals
receive. There's
clinician biases,
stereotypes, and prejudices,
race-based clinical
decision support,
and algorithms, and
a persistent lack of
diversity among
healthcare professionals.
Dr.
Gengopadahaya also
noted that there was a
medical apartheid as
there were inequitable
care for patients
of color. The study
investigated the differences
between black and
white patient safety
measures and using
hospital discharge
records from 27 states.
And in that study,
they saw that
black patients
experience a higher
rate of adverse
patient safety events
on 55% of patient
safety measures.
For 82% of patient
safety indicators, black
patients were significantly
less likely to
be admitted to hospitals
that were classified
as high quality.
And high quality was
defined as the hospitals
that were best at
minimizing patient
safety risk based on the
median of value of a
value of each patient
safety indicator this
same research team found
black patients experience
higher rates of
hospital acquired illnesses
or injuries related
to surgical procedures
relative to white
patients treated in
the very same hospital
within hospital
differences black and
white adverse patient
safety rates remain
when comparing black
and white patients
with similar coverage
types so this
study really just
showed that even within
the same hospital
you have different
populations of groups
specifically here
in racial
groups where the
health care is
not equitable
dr smeedly also noted
and this was adapted
from his presentation
that out of a
systematic review of
15 studies that there
were implicit biases
and health outcomes
confirmed among
healthcare professionals
um against black
latinx dark-skinned
individuals as the
general population
and that implicit
bias was significantly
related to patient
provider interactions
treatment decisions
treatment adherence
patient health outcomes
there was also a
systematic review of 37
studies that confirmed
substantial evidence
of pro-white or light
-skinned anti-black
hispanic american
indian or dark-skinned
biases among a variety
of healthcare professionals
across multiple
levels of training
and disciplines it
was also these these
disparities were also
noted within the
electronic health record
researchers analyzed
a sample of 40 000
history and physical
notes. And you're
going to be learning
how to take soap notes
in the coming months.
But I just wanted
you to be aware of
studies of soap notes
or documentations of
patient encounters.
In this sample size,
they found that 18,000
patients approximately
had sentences containing
negative descriptors,
such as resistant,
non-compliant of
the patient or the
patient's behavior they
sought to determine the
odds of finding at
least one negative
descriptor as a function
of the patient's race
and ethnicity um
controlling force and the
control for socio
-demographic and health
characteristics um when
compared with white people
black patients had
two and a half times
the odds of having
at least one negative
descriptor in the history
and physical notes.
Their findings raise
concerns that there was
stigmatizing language
in the electronic
health records, and it
potentially exacerbates
racial and ethnic
health care disparities.
What is being noted
in this presentation
are studies and
publications that are
bringing light to
a reality of lived
experiences of people
who live in the United
States. You, as an
osteopathic physician
to be, have the
opportunity to be the
difference, to advocate
and to save lives.
This is the current
reality. There are
tensions and challenges
that healthcare
system presents that
are compounding with
many other issues that
may bring barriers
to really provide
good care for people.
The next part of this
presentation will
show you how to
be the difference,
how to advocate, and
how to save lives.